are you watching any sport to you was
still watching hoops yeah well it
seasons about the star what do you think
of this Chinese fall out it's a tough
awesome man it's about him look let's
not let's not [ __ ] it let's call a spade
a spade ya have to almighty dollar yeah
NBA's got billions of dollars rolling in
they knew that going in risky and that's
how they're not the first company no to
make inroads in China and go like II
don't do that we're making millions and
billions of dollars yeah this what and
this was LeBron right here talking about
it
and LeBron is such a sorry going it be
all talk about this is freedom of speech
yes we all do have freedom of speech but
at times there are ramifications for a
negative that can't happen when you're
not thinking about others you know you
only think about yourself so I don't
believe I don't want to get into a word
a word or sentence feud with Darryl with
daryl morey but I believe he wasn't
educated on on the situation at hand and
any spoke and
so many people could have been harmed
not only financially but physically
emotionally spiritually so just be
careful what we will between let me say
what we do even though yes we do have
freedom of speech but there can be a lot
of negative iced tea
freedom of speech just watch what you
say it's hard what you boy doesn't like
Daryl Morey that's for sure
well what you become part of because it
affected his bottom line he's alright
it'll be fun
like if somebody if like Rob palinka
tweeted that he wouldn't have that take
if a Lakers guide tweeted that right he
wouldn't throw him under the [ __ ] bus
its family but it's a guy from the
Rockets oh that's a good point
oh yeah like if you're not educated on
the issues like what education do I need
the fact that they're fighting for
democracy right you know but he's right
though they could have been physically
like I know people in the Lakers
organization that were concerned they
that like they wanted them home like
let's are they gonna come home right are
they going to come home yeah one of my
friends works for the NBA he was over
there and he said the second that it all
kind of went down that after that they
always felt watched after that core you
know when Nixon went to China and the
motorcade from the airport to whatever
like the ambassador's palace everybody
on the street was an actor playing a
person on the street Wow not amazing
didn't want anybody getting out of line
they hired actors to be the guy with the
newspaper walking to his car they had a
lady with a baby that was an actress
like just people just Nixon looking out
the window and fine people here yeah
there were all actors from that whole
route there was all of us praying
they're doing the roles okay do China
doesn't play man I went to China last
year to China dude yeah what to Shanghai
or something oh yeah Shanghai and some
comedy there other areas yeah did comedy
over there for a lot of expats a lot of
that's amazing Theo yeah it was pretty
cool man it was um might have been a
year and a half ago Wow
but China doesn't play do China des but
there was no white people there's nobody
it's just Chinese people
you can't go stay in China you can't
show up in China with no papers and mill
around China doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
I've said it before you walking down the
street in China you die they make a soup
out of you buddy
and they do it gracefully brah now
there's love and there's a lot of like
you know like but they're moving forward
you know I'm saying they're like we're
using you as nutrients
we're gonna go bill you know do whatever
we need to do and stop moving your
install some windows or [ __ ] dude you
got people [ __ ] blow and drywall with
their own mouths bro you know you got
people [ __ ] - you'll have one guy
mixing asbestos in another guy's open
mouth bruh they're not playing yourself
that hair dude I think the easiest job
in the world cuz comedies maybe one of
the hardest ones right
please sketch artist that's got to be an
easy job you know yeah I'll tell you the
easiest job in the world police sketch
artist in China guy comes they go oh my
god Chinese police hell yeah
I just got robbed and they go hey we got
it five five straight black hair
Marlboro Reds yeah we got his photo you
know oh that's awesome man it's me dude
you know it's a that's [ __ ] sales Colin
I think like the easiest job in the
world is probably police sketch artist
in China yeah some guy comes in with a
straight a Chinese policeman I just got
robbed like ya mean who he is
we're on the lookout five five straight
black hair Marlboro Reds smoosh their
nose okay we thought he was an Italian
with Down syndrome maybe all right yeah
or that can also be a Jim Norton if he
has to run to the airport in like an
hour he catch this flight because he's a
little more antsy when he has to go
either way both of our [ __ ]
immaculate oh my goodness
what does here David is arts it's like a
strong area it's Co women's in here over
an hour you know well what is this this
big chunk of wood here look look at this
this used to be a tree or something
there's a table norm is a table oh what
a table like uh you know if you want to
set things on stuff or you don't want to
hold on to stuff all the time
I may be an old chunk of coal here yeah
and I may have been born at night but I
wasn't born last night but if I want to
set things go like emotional baggage or
past relationships are regret I don't
see how this well where's the car at
Abel it's for a table yeah like if you
want to do a puzzle Wow understand what
is this wood yeah this was still is this
done what kind of wood is your tableware
I think maple now did you have to make a
table out of a certain kind of wood or
[ __ ] it lose the umbrellas good I'm
struggling here I loved it man [ __ ] his
clothes I forgot to norm I've asked him
40 times come on yourself well you know
47th time is the charm is what no one
ever says you know um do you think what
these athletes getting back to the
basketball do you think with these
athletes that LeBron is like a business
though it's not even like a person on
the court anymore at a certain point
it's just you're too big you can't do he
can't say anything he wants to he's not
making his own usually does he usually
does yeah
he's usually very outspoken because the
the Commissioner wanted the players to
be available for the media in China
mm-hmm but the commissioner in the NBA
hadn't had an official statement yet so
LeBron was the guy that led the players
to say whoa
work you haven't spoken to the media we
didn't do anything wrong right you
addressed it we're not gonna go talk to
get fed to the Wolves so like that's
LeBrons power hmm is there like okay
it's media day in LeBrons like no it's
not we're not doing media because you
have not spoken to the media you're the
commissioner you're in charge
wow that's that's gravitas man yeah
that's gravity just today the Chinese
state broadcaster said Commissioner Adam
Silver will face retribution sooner or
later for saying that Beijing wanted him
to fire Daryl Morey so like like that
you can't win with these folks is this
gonna run right here yes China suck my
dick
I'll say it in Chinese suck my dick
yeah like [ __ ] relax China [ __ ]
stop China won't stop dude I'm telling
you bro
give us yeah they're gameness but
they're gaming when you when the dog
goes in the cage they [ __ ] decorate
you know when you go to China will
[ __ ] clean house Chinese women bro
doodoo you can't vote there's not even
you're not cleaning house over there man
oh yeah like there's gonna be
retribution to the NBA commissioner like
they're gonna [ __ ] slap his neck when
he's sleeping
you know what though deal they'll
probably get three guys on each other's
shoulders put him in a like a warm-up
outfit get him onto a team and just have
them doing wild layups and then I think
we all know how the Chinese are gonna
but tribution and I'm sober and that is
of course three words how unfastening
one fan raised 43 one Laker fan raised
forty three thousand dollars to hand out
stand with Hong Kong t-shirts at the
Lakers season opener because Hong Kong
was like the season opener that's coming
up a lot in China no no no yeah baby in
jail yeah yeah it's interesting how it's
like well I'm sorry
he raised money to make [ __ ] t-shirts
yeah it was that he didn't mean feel
your money your creeps [ __ ] t-shirt
man yeah people gave him how much 43,000
to make t-shirts
damn I'll teach ya
two bucks to make [ __ ] rules you got
taken how many people can even fit in
the state in yeah it's an it sixteen
thousand twenty twenty-two something so
yeah they got taken but it's just why I
think everybody understand should be
like this every time there's a free
throw airway just going oh like every
time is afraid that you see the audience
they're waving like no sniper sticks
what did you see like some guy goes to
the line for like I don't know like six
people like that's how your [ __ ] with
China the protesters might take offense
to that - that's the crazy thing dude
it's not democracy or not everybody
right to do it people are like it's
their right to throw me out of stable
Center - I'm not [ __ ] doing and I'm a
company man
dude it's I'm not [ __ ] up my Lakers
relationship did you enjoy that clip
well you really would have enjoyed it if
he was watching on a TCL TV
TCL is America's fastest-growing TV
brand it's so fast it's the Carl Lewis
of television brands it's that Florence
Griffith visual jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL usa.com